[Music]
and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review
The Day the Earth Stood Still
[Music]
I've ever seen in my life this guy
Cokely - oh yeah he's not really a guy
he's it he takes her the most strangest
bizarre porn you've ever seen he takes
out the form of G I believe there's a
woman who has a kid
and she's like the greatest mother in
the world she finds out of me or it's
gonna crash into New York City and
rather than tell her kid to get out of
there she says move you click a lot of
parents I would have been panicky to my
kids get out of there she'd much rather
let him die peacefully then so the alien
comes down to earth and a giant rat
grapefruit and he's like we come in
peace and the soldiers are like bang so
many questions to a hospital as quickly
as possible
and when the Kiwis alien wakes up he's
like dude you shot me
bummer so the scientists are giving him
this light detector test but this magic
alien powers Keanu Reeves is giving him
the lie detector test
he's like how do I get out of here she's
go through the doing where can I get
some clothes take mine there - Ichi did
you like sweet November he was cliched
and implausible you die so Keanu Reeves
escaped from the hospital but he's like
dude I need a ride - where's my car nice
mother woman decides to drag him around
and she's such a good mother that she
brings her kids on and this will
certainly dangerous mission I wish my
mother would do that if I didn't eat her
so the mother is like are you going to
kill us
every society on this planet is totally
focused on boomer that's my life so he
unleashes this giant robot named Gordon
what Kevin name is that it sounds like a
Swedish desert me now the pig testicles
so gourd is like a bajillion feet tall
you might be thinking what is he gonna
do isn't an example the people have been
a lot some buildings eat Michael Warren
rushing the bus so people can think for
themselves again no he decides to turn
into mosquitoes have mosquitoes that's a
million times cooler than blowing things
up I think we should I could turn into
mosquitoes wait no I don't that'd be
stupid so the mosquitoes go flying
around sucking the life out of
everything breeze is like haha the
personnel
has already been sucked out of me
tubular but rainy sees that the mother
missin actually love each other because
they come together and talk about the
father's death one year after he died
what a great mother I would have talked
about it a week maybe even a day after
he died but a year so reasons like whoa
there's two nice people on this planet I
better stop destroying it the only
problem is he doesn't know how I kiss
this advanced alien race doesn't believe
in turn-off but especially when it comes
to destroying worlds good it's not
important so reads is like I'm just
gonna put my hand on the ship and see
what happens well so the earth is safe
at last
except all the lights and cars and
electricity and the planet goes off but
we didn't need that anyway I don't live
with lights cars or electricity and I
get along just fine please shoot me so
this movie really was fantastic to make
it's not like that boring black and
white movie with social commentary and
religious symbolism this movie is
Theodore Logan in its party I'm glad to
party on court party on Edie this is
history boom see change change come on J
I need money to protect myself or the
aliens mosquito that's are cheap you
know
[Music]
ah